[Music]
in my career i've never met a single
person with his passion ever
and there's not even a close second i
get bloody i i put my body into the
capture of the hunt
the guy will go anywhere climb any
mountain to to catch a fish in a stream
he's doing basically the work of a
biologist just as as sort of a volunteer
science is important because it's going
to help us protect more populations
these fish that are somewhere only in
one creek some are in one river
it may be just another trout but it's a
special trout and they're all special to
me
[Music]
steve mcmillan what's the first
impression you get when you meet him
nice that looks like a brookie there
yeah it does it's almost difficult to
understand him on the phone because he's
so excited about fish and he talks so
fast
the one word to sum up steve his passion
i work in the big city
work long hours i take a lot of work on
me i have a lot of stress at work
but on weekends i find myself in these
hills
walking long mountain trails to go up
there and try and catch a fish
i feel like i own the place and many
times
i do own the place
about four or five years ago
was the nevada native slam program a
challenge to anglers in nevada to
catch every native species that includes
lahontan cutthroat the bonneville
cutthroat yellowstone cutthroat red band
bull trout and mountain white fish
so i began trekking the state to catch
these six species
it's not easy you need to travel great
lengths to catch some of these species
of fish and they're in extremely
remote rugged locations well steve did
it in in two and a half months for me to
be the first to achieve it uh it was
very humbling the last fish was probably
for most people the easiest one to catch
but for me i drove almost 3 000 miles
over five troops to catch it and when i
caught that thing it was like winning
the super bowl for me it's basically
finding that spot knowing they're there
watching and observing instead of just
being in a rush i practice a technique
i've named cpr capture photograph
release here we go and get a good shot
for posterity he documents everything
that happens that day and he gets stream
temperature air temperature
lengths and weights of fish and pictures
of that and he'll prepare a report and
send it to us
he'll be out on at a stream that that we
haven't been to in 50 60 years and he'll
grab fin clips for us and that fin
sample is used for for genetic analysis
to determine if you know if that
population is genetically pure or
hybridized he has
found species of fish in places that we
had no idea about so he's doing the work
of a biologist just as sort of a
volunteer
[Music]
you